حكنا كثير مهمه وهو موضوع الموارد وتاثير
الزياده السكانيه على الموارد وكمان
لاحظنا بالفيديو اللي انعرض باول شي انه
السبيكر قال الحل الوحيد قال اذا وفقط اذا
كيف بقدر نحل المشكله هي اذا اعتمدنا على
الاستثمار في الاقتصاد الاخضر من اجل
مقاومه موضوع الاحتباس الحراري هلا موضوع
الزياده السكانيه يدخل بصلب موضوع الموارد
او الاحرى لانه نقص الموارد هو احد اهم ال
النواتج السلبيه عن موضوع الزياده
السكانيه فح احكي عن تحديات المستقبل
بموضوع الغذاء والطاقه والماء والنفايات
كوننا عم نحكي عن الارقام واللي هوب هذا
كله قائم على رقم على عدد السكان بال 2050
اللي هو اكثر
ونص مليار في رقم ثاني اهم وح اكثر خطوره
كمان اللي هو التوزع السكاني اصلا لهال
الرقم الكبير حاليا كل مشاكل العالم وال
السكان متوزعين 50% و 50% ريف لكن بال
2050 تبعا الا الاحصائيات الامم المتحده
حيصير 70% وده 30% ريف يبقى الريف حيت قلص
المدن اللي ح تتوحش بالحجم فبالتالي صار
في عننا مشاكل بالغزال مشاكل بالطاقه
مشاكل بالمياه مشاكل بالنفايات
ه طب الحل يعني الحل هيك مشاكل بقول انه
هذا بايد المخططين طيب نحنا كيف كبشر
عاديين ممكن نتعامل مع هذا الامر الواقعي
هو ك حقيقه هو بده يصير الناس حيزيد
والريف يصغر والمدن حتكبر طب نحن كبشر
عاديين كيف ممكن اننا نتعامل مع هلا انا
قعد فكرت كثير يعني كون متمل بالموضوع انه
الحل الوحيد هو اننا ندمج الريف مع
المدينه بحيث هالبنيه هي اللي كانت سكانها
مستهلكين للغذاء مستهلكين للطاقه مستهلكين
للماء صدروا النفايات انهم هن ومبهم
يصيروا
مانجوا الغذاء ه اللي بجوا الطاقه ه تعامل
مع موضوع والنفايات في علم كامل بعالم
العماره اسمه ال او في
يعني هو جزر من الجرين اركتكتشر الكشر
عامل مع هي المفاهيم كيف انه انا وم
ابناني اقدر اصنع احتياجاتي هلا اللي اكثر
واحد رائد بهذا الموضوع اسمه ماكنا لما
عمل هذا المبنى هو كان بتحدي ماشن جرافيك
عملت عنه فيلم اسمه جار المحارم الامام
بامكانكم تدور عليه وهو شي ساعه وص تيبا
فهو كان في بتحدي انه هذا البيت اللي عنده
ممكن اسره سكر حاله باب البيت وتقعد فيه
وتش خلص ما عن اي شي طب بس هذا يعني
تقريبا هو شغل الارياق يعني كيف فينا نحن
نطبق الامور هي على مبانينا الحاليه موضوع
الطاقه موضوع طاقه اليا طاقه الشمس موضوع
المياه
الغذاء هلا نيجي اول شيء لموضوع الطاقه
انا براي الشخصي موضوع الطاقه ما ناكل همه
هجيل هذا ولا بعده نبنا ناكلهم بعد 6.4
مليون سنه الوقت اللي بتكون الشمس
لانه من غير المعقول انه هي طع تاخذ طاقه
بس اللي بنا ناكل همه كمان هو عدم حكمتنا
بالتعامل مع موضوع الطاقه نجي لموضوع
الثاني اوح عن موضوع الطاقه بال
2015 انا عملت هيك دراسه صغيره تقريبا وقت
معرض التقنيات الخضراء
هش انه اذا بيت كامل لاربع اشخاص كيف قدش
انا كلفني لاني شغل كلياته على الطاقه
الشمسيه مو بس تصخين المياه يعني هو دارج
عننا هلا حاليا بس موضوع تسخين المياه لان
كيف بيني كلياته براد غساله تلفزيون كل
هالقصص هي ان شغل على الطاقه الشمسيه
تقريبا وصلت لرقم بال 2015 كان حوالي
مليونين ليره طبعا مليونين ليره رقم بس
فينا نقول انه مع قطع ك هلا حاليا كل
بعاني منه النقطه الثانيه البراد
التلفزيون الغساله كلها هي اليوم مسائ
رفاهيه هلا حاليا ابسط البيود فيها برا
تلفزيون ستالي اذا منطقي جدا بيوم من
الايام صير هذا الرقم هو من اساسيات البيت
مثل البيت لازم يكون فيه بلات لازم يكون
فيه د لازم يكون فيه اي شيء لازم يكون فيه
ط
شمسي الموضوع الثاني موضوع المياه التعامل
مع المياه المياه من برا لعدنا على البيت
من عننا للبيت لا استهلاكنا من بعد
استملاء موضوع لعنا هو موضوع التقنيه كيف
بنا نتعامل بحكمه مع موضوع المياه الموضوع
الثاني هو اعاده الاستخدام حارجع الموضوع
الثالث هو الريسايكل هلا موضوع الريسايكل
نحن يعني على مستوى الافراد وع مستوى
البيوت ما فينا نتعامل ما فينا نعمل شيء
تجاهه يعني هي ب نب كثير يعني مثلا على
مستوى بلده على مستوى مدينه على مستوى
دوله ان نقوم بتير الميا بس في اعاده
استخدام المياه اعاده استخدام المياه لما
كانت القطع المي السنه الماضيه يعني كثير
اكثر من فانا قعدت اطلع ان اليه اللي عم
نستخدمها نحن اصلا يعني ممكن نستخدمها مره
ثانيه يعني واحد اذا توض ممكن نستخدم المي
مره ثانيه اذا غلش اوك نستخدم المي مره
ثانيه فصرنا هيك نعبي الحمام هيك سورور
بعدين لما صارت تيجي المي بوفره ه العاده
هي قتح ليش ما نحن اصلا يكون عننا الوعي
بالتعامل مع المياه يعني بشكل طبيعي م شرط
يكون في عننا ازمه مان لحتى نقدر نتعامل
معها اللي عملته اني عملت تصميم
يعني هيك مبدئي لمنس هي من ذاتها بتفرز لي
المياه شيء مع كيماويات شي ب كيماويات
وشيء يعني غير قابل للتعامل الشخصي بضو
اعاده التير بس هلا حاليا ما عرفتها لانه
نست في مجال التصميم بهال ماص بتوفر لي
حوالي 40% من
المياه موضوع الغذاء وال لما عم نحكي ان
نحن في عننا
قاعده التعداد السكاني يبقى نحن في عننا
ارتفاع بالطلب على الغذاء فبالتالي
انخفاض الغذاء يعني الخفاض المتوفر من
الغذاء وبالمقابل ارتفاع النفايات طيب
هالعلاقه العكسيه هي حتعملي يعني في مشكله
ف طيب نحن ليش ما نحول ه العلاقه العكسيه
هي لعلاقه دائريه حيث كل ما زاد الغذاء
زاد النفايات لكن زادت النفايات وتالي زد
غذاء كيف ننا ممكن الغذاء هذا اصلا نحوله
بطريقه بطريقه هلا ح احكي عنها سماد هذا
السماد العضوي ممكن يعال استخدامه وينزر
فيه فبالتالي نحن كغيرنا العلاقه العكسيه
بنا العلاقه بيناتهم
دائما
اي كمان لاحظت انه كل شخص يوميا في عنده
حوالي نصف كيلو من النفايات النباتيه على
مستوى عائله لاحظوا قديش حيكون الرقم على
مستوى بنائي على مستوى حي قدش في حيكون
طرق فضلات ودش ممكن ننا نستفيد منهم
ونحوله وندخلهم ضمن الدائره
الخضراء تجربتي الشخصيه 16 خ
2015 عننا زيرو اور كلياتها كتعم تعامل
معها به الطريقه
كلول يعني بالزراعه هلا موضوع الزراعه ما
كثير يعني لس عم اطول حاول بس موضوع
النفايات بالنسبه بعتب كبيت من سنه ونص
نفاياته الموضوع الثاني هو موضوع الاك
الاك هو كمان نظام غذائي بيئي مكون من
وعائين الوعاء الاول هو وعاء النباتات
وموصول مع وعاء اسماك بمضخه المضخه هي
بتاخذ لي
المياه الملوثه ب فضلات الاسماك وترفعها
بتغزي فيها النباتات طبعا فضت الاسماك هي
من اقوى الغزيات الطبيعيه للنباتات ونفس
الوقت في مصفايه هي المصفايه اطاء اليه
بيرجع على حوض
الاس طبعا ممكن اعمل ه الشي
كلياتنا اصطنا
بالملك ومليانه كراكيب ورشات وفراشين وقصص
ه العالم صار في ه توجه يعني انا ما عم
بحكي شيء ماال صار في توجه كامل اسمه الين
اركتكتشر كيف ان حولي المبنى المبنى
مستهلك الى مبنى منتج على مستوى م ما تكون
الطاقه الغذاء المياه وصارت في دراسات
كامله كيف اني اعزل الاسقف مير عندي شايه
ما يصير في عندي حشارات ما يصير في عندي
اي نوع من انواع المشاكل اللي ممكن يصير
الحيوي هسيه بس انا كمان حقول لكم
انز هذا صار وضمن ابسط انواع المنازل اللي
لا فيها عزل ولا فيها دراسات انشائيه ولا
فيها اي شيء كثير من
المناطق صارت تصنع غذاءها بشكل ذاتي وا او
ما فيكم 100% يعني المنتجات اللي ممكن
انتاجها
الورقيات الفواتح الصغيره مثل الفريز
والخس القصص رغم وجود التشات نن اكبر
مشاكلنا هي التشات احد مشاكلنا على الاصبح
رغم
وجودها يتعامل
مع طيب في عندي مشكله ثانيه هي انه هو
هالعمليه هي اذا يدويا بدها تصير كم ممكن
تجيب حشرات ممكن تجيب يعني يعني مشكله
ممكن في روائح وحتاخد حوالي شهر ونص طيب
كيف ممكن نتعامل معها كمان هلا حاليا صار
في ادوات على مستوى الحض او حتى على على
مستوى المنزل انه بدل ما تاخذ شهر ونص
بتحط فيها هي الاله تحط فيها اليات خلال
ساعه ونص بتعرضها لنفس العوائل بتج
تفاعلات تصير عليها خلال ض حراره منتفعين
فبتالي خلال ساعه
ونص هلا عفوا هذا الحكي كله بصدد البيئه
المستدامه مو العماره الخضراء اللي كانش
عن شي متكامل هي العماره الخضرا تخ
التنميه المستدامه التنميه المستدامه
تخطون كل الاختصاصات من الاقتصاد ضمن ضمن
العماره ضمن الزيا بس ممكن شرح اكثر عن
عماره خضراء ولو شيء بسيط بعد
بعد حاحكي شويه تجارب هلا مثلا في عننا
بلده في الموردن هي ببريطانيا بلده عاديه
جدا ما فيها اي مميز لا فيها مميز لا فيها
ميزات زراعيه ولا تعليميه ولا اي شيء ولا
اسبيه ولا اي شيء قرار المجلس البلديه انه
يعمل شيء غريب بالبد فعملوا هي التجربه كل
شيء كل النفايات حولوها طو طويله وزرعوا
مو زرعوا الا زرعوا الشوارع زرعوا الحدائق
ب اللان سكيب العادي اللي بنلاقيه شويه
صفاره وشجر عادي نا حولوه لغذاء فصار
عندهم غذاء مجاني للجميع الشغله الثانيه
اللي استفادو هو انه نشطوا مفهوم جديد
للسياحه اسم السياحه الزراعيه وهو انه
السائح بيجي بيتفرج شوي المدينه اللي
كلياتها ضار وكلياتها فواكه ف
يعني
التجربه الثانيه هي الاتحاد الاوروبي
الاحصائيه عن الدول اللي قامت الزراعه
العضويه القائمه كمان على الملقات
النباتيه اعلى كانتس وصلت لحوالي 20% من
اراضيه الزراعيه كلياتها لمات اليما
ويعتمدوا على موضوع الزراعه
العضويه الثانيه هي السويت وع فكره السويت
هي من الدول اللي هي مو بس بتتعامل مع
نفايات صار تشتري نفايات من غير دول لحتى
تتعامل مع
موضوع التخمير الهوائي عفوا اللا هوائي
بستفيد منحتاج غاز الميتان والهوائي
بستفيد منه
المضوع هلا حكي شويه ارقام كون الاعن
الارقام هو انه اذا اسره مؤلفه من اربع
اشخاص بدي اكفيها بشكل تام يعني من كل
الخضار بدي حوالي 4 متر
مربع
الانسان بده بالساعه 50 لتر
اكسجين الورقه النبات ورقه النبات العادي
يعني مو الورقه الورقه
العاديه بتنتج حوالي 5 مل من الاكسجين
يبقى اذا الانسان قاعد بغرفه مغلقه ومعه
كميه نباتات يعني تعطيه حوالي 10000 ورقه
فهو قادر انه يعيش بدون ما يستهلك ولا
اكسجين الشيء الثاني بدي اقوله انه مثل ما
ق انه الاسره من اربع اشخاص يوميا في
عنيات عضويه حوالي 2
ك هلا انا حاولت بال 2015 كمان اني اعمل
جروب
اسمه هو مو بس عن عماره هو عن اي شيء له
علاقه بالتنميه مستدامه ومواضيع البيئه
والتوعيه
للاسف كانت الاستجابه
مش اللي اكتشفته انه نن ما الموضوع يعني
حتى مثلا لو
حسنا يعني اذا بدي للعالم النفايات
بالنهايه لما حيطلعوا على الشارع الفط مع
باضه
وح
الحشرات فالموضوع
دع يعني هي القصص ما بال 2016 بحكي عن
2015 ر لكن اذا لدينا هلا مع الاطفال اللي
ههم الكيجي هدول ي 2050 حيكونوا بال 35
يعني هن بيعز انتاجه ووعيه وانتاجه للجيل
اللي بعده فبالتالي نحن بكون حققنا الهدف
يعني اذا اشتغلنا من هلا على موضوع
الاطفال
اقلها 2050 حنلاقي النتيجه المجوع مص
اي مثل ما مواردنا صح محدوده لكن مو
المشكله بال الموارد المحدوده مثل ما انه
الزياده صح مشكله بس مو المشكله الزياده
المشكله هي التعامل الحكيم مع الزياده
والتعامل مع الموارث لانه ها مو ملك خاص
لنا هي ملك للاجيال القادمه
ش